[Music]
hello and welcome to a special edition
of the view from 22 uh we are in a port
cabin in South London at the arc or Ark
uh and this is a big uh several day
conference here in London discussing and
debating many things one of the things
that is being talked about uh is energy
and I'm delighted to be joined today by
Robert Bryce uh who is uh a brilliant
American writer on energy author of many
books uh and you've submitted a paper
for this conference yeah um on
electrification correct and your thesis
and this has been the thesis of quite a
lot of your work is that Net Zero
policies are hampering progress in terms
of real
progress I think the britishism would be
Looney Round the Bend bonkers Crazy Town
yes not gonna happen give us a sort of
overview of quite how bad quite how
badly necessary policies are hampering
Global growth well I can't say oh it's
hampering by one% two percentage points
what you know but I think the entire uh
scenario the entire thesis of these Net
Zero claims they're just they it won't
happen this Net Zero goal it won't
happen because it can't happen the the
constraints we live in a world Freddy
with defined by networks we live in a
world of network a network of networks
right we don't think about it much but
you know I've ridden the tube here and
it's just amazing right you know much
cleaner and faster than the subway in
New York City for instance you know
maybe it's not as good as Paris I don't
know but you know but it's amazing right
well the network of systems that are
connecting there whether it's part of
the electric grid and the rail systems
and the rail workers and the the the
Personnel that maintain that system and
trucks and crms and overhead rigging and
all these other things that work
together so this idea that we're
suddenly going to change the entire
underpinning of the modern global
economy which runs 80% on hydrocarbons
Co oil and natural gas and do so in you
know 30 years it's Madness there's no
way we can make it happen because if we
just start with land use and this is one
of the issues I don't talk about in the
in the uh powering the unplugged paper I
did for Arc but it's been a long F long
focus of mine there's not enough land
for all the renewable junk you you're a
Brit you know about this very vicious
battles across rural Britain across
rural Scotland uh just a week ago in in
North Devon which is 300 clicks 300 kilm
West of here enormous opposition to a
high voltage transmission line that's
proposed to carry power from an offshore
wind project to the grid onshore so this
opposition is happening all around the
world the problem is fundamentally with
Renewables there many problems including
intermittency we don't have enough land
for all these winter bat killing and
bird killing wind whale killing B wind
turbines they want to build nor is there
enough land for all the solar panels
they claim that will be needed to even
make a a dent in hydrocarbon overall
contribution so there are many problems
with net zero that's just one of them
the cost is astronomical YN lomberg was
just presenting on this it won't happen
because it can't happen yes well and
that points towards a fundamental lack
of
realism in uh global leaders about about
what they're doing because as you point
out in your work um coal usage has
increased
dramatically yeah give us some of the
stats on that I it's sure sure well I I
I think about I laugh about this
sometimes because it's almost 10 years
ago I debated a guy named Shaw he
made his he made a fortune in the Solar
business in the United States and you
know good for him but I remember
distinctly we were debated in New York
and I pointed out at that time that cold
demand was Rising globally and he says
Ah you know doesn't matter solar's going
to take over the world okay well where
are we the Ia just released a report
just a few weeks ago in fact that said
Global coal demand will set another new
record this year of 8.4 billion
tons last year China it permitted two
new coal powered plant two new Coal
Fired power plants a week they're
they're going to add 100 gwatt of new
Coal Fired capacity Indonesia Vietnam
Japan is building Coal Fired power
plants I was in Tokyo earlier this this
year TECO which owns Tokyo Electric
Tokyo Electric power company owns
Fukushima daichi they are building an
ultra super critical coal plant on Tokyo
Bay right now now they're also adding 5
gwatt of new gas fired capacity so 2
gwatt of coal capacity in Japan home of
the Kyoto
Protocol you know so the reality is that
I call it the iron law of electricity
people countries and businesses will do
whatever they have to do to get the
electricity they need and that includes
building coal plants and lots of them
and you didn't mention Germany though
which is also going back yes we were
laughing about talking about Germany
before we started recording explain
Germany I mean I can't you know and if I
were better person maybe a better
Christian I'd feel badly for them I
don't
sorry they drove themselves into the
ditch at speed you know with this energy
Venda and they're going to waste a
trillion dollars or more and the result
is be is going to be economic ruination
they're de-industrializing they're
facing uh declining not only negative
economic growth today their biggest
industrial firms are saying we're going
overseas some a lot of them are going to
come to the US yes and you know I'm I
live in Texas I'm from Oklahoma us but
this is you know bad for Germany it's
bad for Europe and what you know Germany
is the biggest economy in Europe so if
Germany declines is going to have
effects Ripple effects throughout the
continent but they tied themselves to to
Russian gas and I you know you can blame
Angela Merkel for part of this you can
blame her as well and some of the other
politicians for this energy Venda which
is just absolutely ruinous and they're
not building they're not building they
can't build enough Renewables they've
had wind droughts last year that were
you know put them on the edge of black
outs so you know this these ideas around
you
know you know hitching our economy
either in Germany or the UK or any
economy in the world solely to these
weather dependent Renewables it's just
Madness well the reason I didn't laugh
quite as mirthfully as you about Germany
it's not because I'm a nice person but
it it led me to think that actually
Britain is going to be is slightly
behind Germany on this I think in terms
of encountering that iron law of energy
that you were talking about because for
all our Pride that we take in being you
know a leading country in terms of Net
Zero targets Etc uh we are going to
pretty soon have to face the reality
that our energy policies don't add up
our energy is getting extremely
expensive right um and we might start
having to think about going backwards in
terms of you know the green
agenda to be able to produce you've
already seen this I mean it was just a
couple of weeks ago your prime minister
rishy sunak uh you know after being Mr
Net Zero for a while then says oh by the
way I remember his words now we're going
to be realistic and pragmatic right
those were the words I remember it I
wrote about it and well why is he doing
it he's looking around and looking at
the politics of this and realizing if I
don't Backtrack on this it's going to be
we're going to be out of office now and
what happened now you probably saw the
poll numbers right in the week after he
did that the Tories came up in the polls
Four Points yes but they managed to take
care of that pretty quickly and get
themselves back down quite they had a t
Party Conference of complete
dissol um but I mean I wonder on uh uh
on that sort of subject well I'm sorry
to interrupt I'm sorry to interrupt but
so but Liz truss came in for what you
know two cups of coffee and right and
she said we're gonna we're going to
start fracking again right you know and
then and which was absolutely the most
sane policy that she could do right
particularly in the wake of the Russian
war Britain has significant Shale gas
resources and ones that potentially are
even richer than the Shale gas resources
in the United States which is saying
something because they're enormous right
so the gains were uh gain were a trough
mentioned George Yates from heo energy
just you know he's investing in the UK
the amount of energy the gas in places
the numbers are just staggeringly large
but you have to drill for them so you
had truss come in and say we're going to
repeal the fracking ban and then you you
then sunac comes in and says oh no we're
going to keep the fracking ban in place
what are you not paying attention I mean
truly I mean this is just it's an insane
approach given the vulnerability of the
British economy to these swings in in
natural gas prices you're importing what
uh half or a third of your gas now I
mean so you've got to be drilling and
and producing more of your own resources
and yet you don't seem to be that your
politicians don't seem to care and what
do you put that lack of care down to I
mean it's probably a bit too easy to
sort of dismiss it as just Eco zealotry
um is there something more fundamental
going on is there a sort of
unwillingness to confront decline as a
nation or something like that well then
i' I'd be speculating of course on that
because I can't you know I I live in
Texas so I'm no hardly an expert on
British politics but uh George Yates I I
interviewed him this morning for my
podcast the power hungry podcast and I
asked him that very question about
what's going on he said it's this he
called it the institutionalization of
the green agenda so that it's been
bought into here in the UK by both the
Tories and by labor and that makes some
sense to me I mean it sounds right right
because the the stories that I read
whether I read about sunak was that he
had strong supporters in the Tory party
who didn't want frac right I guess they
have the states and you know and they
didn't want drill rigs in their
neighborhoods up you know wherever
they're so maybe that's the case but you
you know I'm all for sobriety very
cleare eyed approaches to the energy and
power these are the most important
sectors of the economy here in Britain
and around the world and you you mess
them up you them up we're on a
podcast so I can say this word it's your
extreme Peril yeah and and yet you still
haven't repealed the fracking ban and
sunak kind of gone on this half step of
saying well we'll go back in the North
Sea okay well go ahead but you know you
have massive resources here on Shore and
I'll just end with this one quick
point maybe it's obscure history but
it's important history nevertheless
there's an an intriguing book that was
written called The Secret of Sherwood
Forest and maybe you know about this in
1943 a bunch of Drillers from Oklahoma
came to Britain during the war and they
drilled in Sherwood Forest and with the
span of a year they drilled over 100
Wells and went from zero production to
3,000 barrels a day in Britain yes in
the span of a year well I mean up until
the 1970s and ' 80s we were a energy
exporting country right because you're
the you found the North Sea and it was
just amazing right you know I think and
then it peaked in the 90s and I think
it's been declining ever since I'm not
remembering those numbers exactly but
you you discovered the North Sea and
then you just quit yeah well you got to
keep going well when um rishy sunak our
Prim Minister made this uh slight
reverse veret yeah uh on Net Zero not a
proper reverse veret but a slight
deviation um one of the things that was
talked about a lot is uh if we are going
to continue using hydrocarbons in a
pragmatic and sensible way but still
trying to honor Net Zero obligations uh
we would have to use a lot of carbon
capture uh what is your view of that is
that a bit of a uh a sort of phantom is
that a realistic and credible future for
for hydrocarbon production to to sort of
carbon Capt in a way that it makes it
Net Zero friendly no good good thank you
we'll just move
on
uh so sure it's a scale problem Freddy I
mean just very simply um so let's take a
typical PL Power Plant say it's uh 100
megawatts well to capture the carbon
from that power plant you have a
parasitic load that's the term of art of
30% or so so your 100 megawatts of
output is now 70 megawatts well then you
have a big bunch of you know carbon
dioxide that's a colorless odorless
worthless gas that's heavier than air
and it's an asphyxiant oh and it's
corrosive so you're going to build a
pipeline to then take that gas somewhere
Freddy we can't build pipelines that
carry products that are valuable like
oil and gas right I mean there's always
opposition to them right yeah how are we
going to build pipelines of any length
to carry a colorless oess worthless gas
that's heavier than a and it's fixing in
and it's corrosive right how are you
gonna do this I mean and go slowly
because I'm from Oklahoma a little dumb
right but it doesn't make any sense to
me when you take just those parts of it
together and then you have to find a
reservoir that will accept that much CO2
you have to pump it down there
effectively if you look at I remembering
my numbers just off the top of my head
but I wrote a book in 2010 called Power
hungering the myth of green energy the
real fuels in the future I just did the
simple math so if you just want to
sequester 10% of global CO2 10% give or
take you would have to replicate the
enti entire Global oil and gas sector in
Reverse yeah in order to take that
massive amount of CO2 and pump it down
in the ground so I my view on CCs is
that you know yes they're now big tax
credits in the US and there are a lot of
companies chasing what's called 45q
under the inflation reduction act and
there's billions of dollars available so
some companies are doing it okay great
but it's a boutique thing that will
never scale so my my final point on that
if we're going to be serious about this
combustion in CO2 we can't burn it first
we have to use nuclear we have to avoid
as much combustion as possible well that
was going I was going to get onto
nuclear my next question just to finish
on CCS you'd say carbon capture you'd
say it's at best a sort of fig Leaf to
carry on using
hydrocarbons uh yeah you call it a fig
Leaf I just call it a bad
idea I call I could call it an idea
that's been around I wrote a piece in
the New York Times that published down
2010 yeah pointing out the problem scale
corrosion you know the the the the
problems the mass and you know approvals
and the rest of it I wouldn't change a
word word of it today yeah and so look
around the globe we have tiny handful of
projects that are doing CCS at and and
they're very small so the idea that
we're going to ramp them up and we're g
to finally you know make this scale up I
I'm I'm I'm all day skeptical well um I
was going to ask about nuclear because
uh on my podcast not on this show on my
podcast Americano recently we had uh
Oliver Stone the film director nuclear
now yeah yeah uh and I thought it was
quite an interesting film actually and
it was quite eccentric coming from
Oliver Stone yeah but um I mean he made
this point very forcefully from the left
from the political left that nuclear is
the only option uh for the future of the
planet and it sounds to me like you
you'd agree with that I've been
pronuclear for a long time my my view on
nuclear is very simple if you're
anti-carbon dioxide and anti-nuclear
you're Pro blackout yeah yeah well I'm
anti blackout I'm very anti-black out I
live in Texas I was blacked out in 2021
for two days right during law Pro would
if true Pro anybody everybody's anti
blackout we can pretend that we could
live in some primordial age but we can't
yeah you you're welcome to do it I don't
want to do it you know have you have had
it Freddy but so I'm adamant pronuclear
and I think What's happen you're make
you're getting some traction here in
Britain with you started seze wellc
right you know construction is underway
that's a good step forward and you're
having this tender offer now around uh
this new small modular reactor design
and um maybe Rolls-Royce I know is one
one of the contenders right which um for
this this design and and approval
process I think particularly in the wake
of the Russia Ukraine war this is an
imperative for all of Europe and my view
is that Europe maybe Poland maybe
Romania maybe France will be the first
to deploy a new small modular reactor
because they have the political will to
make it
happen but I think the Russia Ukraine
war makes that that gives much more
importance strategic importance to that
development of nuclear in Europe um r R
Mania may be the odds on favorite right
because of their their government has
been pronuclear they're very technically
very good um I know one of one of our
guys behind the camera here is it from
Bucharest so he's he's nodding and back
there saying that's great Romania go
Romania um but there are a lot of
hurdles let's be clear and very again
very sober about what those hurdles are
right because you got to get the
regulatory approval you need a lot of
capital and you have to get the fuel and
right now Russia controls 46% of the
global enriched uranium market so in the
US now we're getting roughly 25% of the
fuel for our nuclear reactors from
Russia well Russia's not our friend and
so you know how long will that continue
we don't know right so the US is slowly
ramping up uranium production here in
the in the UK I guess you're GNA have
ureno which I think is German Dutch
French uh no German Dutch British I
think you're you're going to start more
enriching more uranium here on the
continent but you better get cracking I
mean you know this is an imperative that
that if if if climate matters right
otherwise go back to Coal well nuclear
is stable but it's not entirely reliable
I'm not just talking about the danger
there I'm talking about the upkeep of it
I mean in France in the last year and a
half is yeah well they're terrible
operators I mean they just neglected why
did the fren why did that happen with
the French they weren't operating their
plants very well right you you're GNA if
you're going to build a house and you're
going to keep it for a while you got to
do you got to paint it you got to do you
know this they've missed a lot of those
maintenance things that should have
happened why why is it happening now why
didn't it happen 10 years ago they were
better operators so I blame that
extraordinarily bad timing too with the
war in Ukraine breing of course um but I
a point that was made in that Oliver
Stone film that I'd like to get your
opinion on is that the uh this the the
environmentalists left in America the
Sierra Club Green Piece they were
initially quite pronuclear and this was
something I was unaware of really um and
Stones theing it's possibly slightly
conspiratorial uh is that uh Big Oil
essentially funded anti-nuclear
propaganda on the left and made
everybody allergic to the idea of
nuclear power and a nuclear future do
you think there's much credibility do
you think that sounds true I've heard
those claims before I've never seen any
proof of that I don't you know today I
will I will tell you I don't know
anybody in the oil and gas business and
I know a fair number of people in the
oil and in the energy generally broad
energy sector broadly I don't know a
single one of them is anti-nuclear yeah
and so it's easy to talk about
conspiracies and remember you know all
due respect he also made the film about
johnf Kennedy and right kind of you know
conspiracy theories are us right yeah
right yeah um I don't I look I'm a
longtime critic of the Sierra Club the
natural resources defense Council
environmental defense fund all of these
big NOS in the United States I don't
like those people I don't like them at
all and I'm sure they don't like me back
and I'm just fine with that but I find
they're a parasitic force in American
politics they are unaccountable
extraordinarily well-funded they're
spending on the order of 4 and a half
billion dollars a year that's just the
25 largest ones and the policies They
are promoting including their
anti-nuclear stands is absolutely
corrosive in our in our in our overall
politics and and and and the the the
reliability affordability and resilience
of our electric grid I I I I have no
tolerance no no patience for any of
those people I think they they they are
very powerful they're very effective
give them credit but they have been
anti-nuclear for decades because it
suits a narrative that fits their agenda
which is this all renewable all the time
narrative but it can't work it won't
work and they know I think
intellectually if you pin them down they
will acknowledge it but I find them all
just completely dishonest and and
further I think the part that I I just
grills my cheese as my late brother John
Bryce would say was they don't
have any understanding of what this
means for the poor in the middle class
and all of these policies including
natural gas banss including these
electric car mandates electric vehicle
charging it all screws the poor in the
middle class all of it and and I just
find that reprehensible and as you point
out in your paper women in the
developing World well right and so but
that I think we can separate some of the
issues that I talk about thank you for
bringing up my paper it's called
powering the unplugged yeah um it's on
the The Alliance for responsible
citizenships website uh you can find it
on my substack Robert bryce. substack
docomo all of it there and I'm proud of
the paper and I I'm proud of the paper
for a lot of reasons one it's it's
flattering to be asked by this new group
and I'm I'm longtime fan of Jordan
Peterson bjor lomborg and and what the
work that they do but this idea we need
a better vision for the future right
well if we can't have that better Vision
unless we have a very sober and and
clear look at where we are in terms of
energy and power and where is what is
the biggest challenge and the one that I
think is the most urgent is how do we
bring more energy and power to uh uh
poor women and girls in developing
countries because they are the most
vulnerable in societies and so a point
that I make in the in the paper and one
that I mentioned I I did an monologue
this morning talking about my paper for
for Arc a few years ago you should look
it up on YouTube Hans rosling the late
Swedish demographer did this great video
and it just I I recommend it a lot
because it's so powerful so he's dead
now and he's probably died at age 70
something or other but he comes on stage
I think it's a TED talk I'm not sure but
he comes on stage and he tells a story
about his grandmother and that when he
was a child his parents bought a washing
machine and it was a big day and on that
day his grandmother came over and he
reenacts it he puts the clothes in the
washer and there's actually a washing
machine on stage with him and he pulls
the clothes out of the bucket and he
puts him in the washer and he closes it
and he remembers that the day that they
got the washing machine the day had had
it all hooked up his grandmother came
over and she said I want to be the one
that pushes the button to start the
washing machine because she had her
whole life washed clothes by hand and
you twin that with his other his other
key point which is that there are five
billion people in the world today
walking around in clothes that have been
washed by hand well if there are five
billion people walking around with
clothes that been washed by hand that's
means two and a half billion women and
girls are doing that washing yes and
every hour every minute every day that
they're humped over that wash bucket you
know that's is an hour a day in a minute
that they're not in the library or at
school or looking for a job or doing
something to be independent so this the
the importance of energy and electricity
in particular to women and girls cannot
be overstated as I say in one of my
favorite lines electricity frees women
and girls from the pump the stove and
the wash tub yes power is empowering
exactly very well put yeah exactly power
is power power equals power but it's Inc
it is it is absolutely essential for
women and girls yes and just to in case
people start screaming sex say you're
not saying that women have to do those
chores you're saying that in those
societies people can scream whatever
they want I can't hear them from here
that's good people would those we'll
just have to listen look I'm not saying
look but this is just a fact and it's
there's no sexism here let's move Beyond
this you know wokeism and let's
recognize what the real story is here
and some some data that i s in the
report a few years ago UNICEF did
published a report on the state of
children globally and what did they find
that the that the uh uh the countries
that have the highest rates of child
marriage where women are or girls are
married before the age of 18 and many
before the age of 15 are highest in the
countries where there's no power no
electricity right so these are
effectively these women are effectively
slaves in these countries where they
don't have electricity well and to go
back to that poers empowering Point
there's some very interesting charts in
your paper on that on the number of
things that map very neatly positive
things that we think about that map very
neatly with levels of power levels of
access to power GDP I mean you can look
at I I screen grabbed a couple of charts
that the iea did a few years ago and
they uh showed GDP and electricity they
just March in Tango all the time right
you know they're right next to each
other all the time that this is what you
know this is how it works well
electrification has to be the future
whichever way you look it it I think
that's fair to say unless we go
backwards entirely we need we need
enormous amounts of new generation
globally if we're going to try and when
you talk about electrification I mean
there's also this push of Electrify
everything this is in the rich countries
which is a bad course of action in terms
of affordability resilience and
reliability but the big challenge is
that this electrification challenge in
developing countries consider this so
Pakistan Indonesia and India by
themselves on per capita basis use are
part of what I call the unplugged world
so they use less those those those 1.9
billi million people roughly a quarter
of the world's population live in
locations where per capita consumption
of electricity on average is less than
what's consumed by a kitchen
refrigerator in the US so these are
massive disparities so how do we
overcome those well it's incredibly
difficult but nuclear has to be part of
that answer there's a lot of interesting
technologies that could be deployed at
scale thorcon is one of them it's a
company it's a US company they have a
molten salt reactor that they're putting
on ships the perfect answer for
Indonesia because it's a archipelago
right so you're going to not you know
you could build these ships you could
put them right on the coast and then
that plug in the plug in the grid to the
ship right so we're not lacking good
ideas on the technology front we're
lacking uh political will we're lacking
um confidence I think is one of the
other key points what about just uh
quickly what about nuclear fusion there
there's some excitement about that in
Britain do you think that's a
viable look I'm an old man Freddy I'm 63
years old I've heard about it since I
was a kid it's always been 20 years away
and they're still about 20 years away
now there is a lot of momentum and a lot
of money behind Fusion now right and and
I'm you know I'm Pro technology right
I'm I'm not a skeptical that it could
eventually work but fion works great
freaking go after fion let's deploy fion
and just get on with it right we can we
know this will work why not focus on
this I'm not saying we don't shouldn't
be investing in Fusion but I don't think
it's I don't see a viable pathway at
gigawatt and terawatt scale in the near
term because of all the technical
challenges around high heat radiation
and all these other things that you have
to solve and they're devilishly
difficult to solve and and they're and
if they weren't devilishly difficult
they would have been solved by now and
in sometime in my lifetime G give us a
sense of just how much power is going to
be needed by the world in the next 50
years sure so if you look back the best
records we can see that the global
generation capacity is doubling every 20
or 25 years right so um we're now I'm
trying trying to think of uh we're us
has about one ter or one trillion uh one
1.2 trillion watts of capacity um
globally I think it's uh something like
what is it uh seven or eight terawatts
something like this memory Ser memory
service so we're going to have to over
the next then 20 years we're going to
have to build six or seven grids the
size of the US globally to meet this you
know anticipated demand that's a lot of
Steel a lot of copper a lot of
generators a lot of stuff that we're
going to have to do so if from the
material intensity part of this which is
a power density Story the best way to go
forward when that is is with nuclear
because it requires less stuff yeah wind
requires you know copper steel you know
all the rest of it in enormous amounts
on the orders of you know 10 15 times
more than natural gas and Nuclear So I
those are the things that been saying
for a long time in to end natural gas to
nuclear that's the way forward and
there's enough there's enough uranium in
the world to keep us going for a long
time I I think there's going to be
plenty of it especially if we reprocess
it and you know and and let me be clear
none of this is going to be cheap or
easy or quick I mean these and that's
why this idea of Net Zero in 30 years
we're going to you know completely
change the global economy and run it all
and you know unicorn farts and fairy
dust no you're not it's not it doesn't
work that way yeah right it's going to
be it's going to take a long time it's
going to cost a lot of money and and we
have to be very sober about where we're
spending our money because especially in
the US we're running these massive
deficits and so got to be very cleare
eyed about what where we're going and
why I wonder what you think of groups
like uh just up oil we have in Britain
um I hate those groups I hate them with
a burning passion for I got a feeling
that that might be the I want I want
those kids that are throwing the soup on
those paintings I want to send them
here's my if I'm the judge okay young
lady or young young man or whoever you
are your sentences seven years you have
to go live in an African village out in
the you know wherever 200 miles from the
nearest town of any size and you are not
allowed to use hydrocarbons for that
entire time and then I want you come
back and tell me how you like
it that's my No incarceration but you
cannot leave that Village no handcuffs
no prison jumpsuits but you cannot use
coal oil or natural gas anytime no
propane
you have to go and live on cow dong and
twigs and wheat straw and then report
back and you tell me how you think
you're just going to stop oil you
spoiled little
brat that's great that's that's the
nuclear reaction I wanted to to generate
I watch it and I just think oh you
entitled narcissistic
Punk uh well I I I mean but what I would
like to say to is that those groups are
uh popular oh yeah they have a lot of
sway with young people people it's
increasingly the way a lot of young
people think a lot of people in Britain
not just young people actually a lot of
people of all ages think that the world
is about to um melt yeah uh and um this
is the biggest uh political problem in
terms of powering the future if we're
going to power the future is that an
enormous number of people will support
policies that however realistic they are
feel to them as though they're
addressing climate change and Net Zero
does that and they're doing something
right and they're taking some action and
that they're you know by lying down in
the middle of the motorway they're going
to make a difference yeah well don't lie
down in front of me on the motorway you
might get run over
twice um you know I'm joking about that
but it you know but it's it it it those
groups the way they do it and the way
the the self the entitlement that they
show I mean that there's a kind of this
blank I I watch these videos of when
they're arrested or where ordinary
citizens are saying get the hell off the
road what are you doing we have lot
you're backing up traffic for Miles here
and they're pulling and they're they're
s they're like passive and they're
melting you know they're I think how is
it that you got to this point in your
life that this is the most meaningful
thing you can do yeah but it the part
that i' I thought about this a lot
recently is it's it's they're activists
right but it's as though I'm just going
to be part of this club right and it's
like I can be in the Boy Scouts can be
in this affinity group without any
understanding of what it is that they're
they're trying to do in terms of the
system and the culture and the broader
Society about what they're saying and
how nonsensical and in fact how
dangerous it is so they only identify
it's like well this is my identity is
I'm a climate Hawk right I'm a climate
activist right and so it's an affinity
group that is this kind of cool club
without
any very very sober understanding of
what it is that they're actually
promoting and what they're actually
promoting is poverty and economic ruin
because there is no you know without oil
the global economy stops and that's just
a fact well and like a lots of
radicalism and a lot of even Cults you
could say uh the more hatred they
generate the more they're convinced
they're right happier they are well they
they're convinced that they're on to the
true P their own moral certitude about
it right but it's but Michael
shellenberger presented on this the
other day and he pointed out there's
there's a form of narcissism there with
that kind of attitude and I just have no
patience for it and I I I partly you
know I'm old and grumpy you know as part
of it but it's also this is my life work
right this is what I do this is my
purpose and my passion to think and
right talk about energy and power and
their importance to everyone and to have
this kind of BL kind of oh well let's
just quit doing it because it's not cool
and you know we're going to put up wind
turbin and solar panels well have you
ever talked to anyone that has been had
their wind turbines and solar panels put
right next to their house or do you have
any idea of what it is scale of what it
is that you're talking about do you have
any idea of the consequences of what
would happen to our society if you are
right you like the idea of horeshit in
the street I mean not just a little bit
but you know feet deep horeshit in the
street because without oil we're our
cars go away oh electric cars okay fine
well then are you in favor of child
labor in the in the Congo to produce the
Cobalt that Elon Musk needs to build his
Teslas does that Ryme would you like
that are you in favor of poverty for
women and girls in Africa and indoor air
pollution because they don't have
propane and they can only burn dung I
mean mgat Wade has talked about this at
this conference and many times and very
passionately about it but you know her
passion for it has kind of ignited
another passion in me because that is
the nut of it young lady are you really
in favor of keeping all these women and
girls in poverty are you really in favor
of one or two or three million women and
girls dying every year from from lung
disease because they're they can't use
propane and instead in using using
biomass uh to cook their ho their their
meals is that really what you're in
favor of if so stand up and be counted
then because you're anti-human and
you're spoiled brat go
away well I we you you've light you've
lit me up here Freddy I haven't had a
drink I'm not even I'm dead sober here
maybe a little too much coffee it's I
I'm enjoying it um I but so far we've
managed to avoid uh probably because
it's usually quite a boring debate but I
think we probably should I probably
should ask this question uh you're
presumbly not a climate
alarmist uh by any measure but what is
your view of the climate change debate
where do you where do you where do you
put yourself on the kind of um it is
happening and it's terrible and it is my
answer is climate change is a concern
yeah it's not our only
concern whatever policy we take toward
climate change we have to be very
careful and cleared and sober about what
that policy means and who it impacts so
we have to be careful that it doesn't
hurt the poor in the middle class and
then let's look around and see what
policies have been promulgated and how
it's affecting the poor in the middle
class okay let's look at California
what's happened since Arnold
Schwarzenegger mandated all you know
these renewable mandates starting in
2008 electricity prices in California
have gone up three times faster than the
rest of the us as a whole where are the
highest power prices in America in San
Diego California right now 47 and a half
cents a kilowatt hour yeah it's insane
it's almost three times the national
average
so yes I I don't doubt CO2 is a
greenhouse gas I don't doubt that if we
you know from what a lot of the
scientists say that if we you know flood
the atmosphere with CO2 it may affect
the climate I don't doubt that that's a
possibility but I also am very clear
about listening to both sides and Bjorn
lomberg makes a very clear and
compelling case that yes it's a concern
but it's not the most concern right now
and it's not the best place for us to
spend our tax dollars because the
payback in the benefit of doing all this
radical these radical moves toward alt
energy will be more costly than the
benefit so I think that kind of cleare
eyed analysis is very much needed um but
it's one reason why I don't argue about
CO2 or parts per million and I don't my
view is Let's do let's take the best no
regrets strategy going forward and what
is that natural gas and nuclear least
material intensity highest power the
Technologies are mature and scalable
they're low Carbon Let's get with it on
that note uh Robert before the lights go
out because we are in London and it
could
happen let's hope not or at least not
wait till after about 12 o'clock on
Saturday because that's when my wife and
I are flying out so after that yeah well
whatever we'll find enough gas to put in
the in the plane oh I hope so um thank
you very much my pleasure Freddy all the
[Music]
best